this year's nfl draft here in las vegas
starts april 28th right now preparations
are already underway and as we approach
draft day it will get tougher to get
around the strip corridor mary jane
bellies is live on the strip with what
we need to know to maneuver the area
mary jane
starting the night of wednesday april 27
through saturday april 30th the las
vegas strip boulevard will be closed
that's from flamingo stretching down to
bellagio drive and to koval lane whether
you're working or attending the draft
you do need to start planning alternate
transportation now as it won't be easy
to park
the end of april means a packed weekend
with the nfl draft on the las vegas
strip with closures and crowds it means
a lot of traffic congestion the nevada
taxi authority is working with metro
police and the county on alternate
routes and transportation due to road
closures and lane reductions jd decker
with the taxi authority says one of
those options is providing enough taxis
for visitors and easy access to rides on
the strip with the road closures that
changes um the traffic and the pickup
and drop-off pattern for transportation
so that's one of the major issues is
that
we've had to relocate and and
consolidate the
transportation options
so we've been working with the
convention authority to
set up a central location off of the
strip
for
taxis and uber and lyft and public
transportation options decker also warns
of unlawful rides that's when unverified
drivers accept cash for rides which can
lead to robberies or other crimes decker
advises to get a ride from a
transportation hub or sticking to
rideshare apps other transportation
options include rtc buses and the
monorail
all right now back out here live there
will be major delays during the draft
weekend so if you're working on the
strip or working the draft remember you
need to leave early and we'll be posting
a full list of those lane reductions and
road closures on our website at eight
newsnow dot com reporting live from the
strip mary jane balleza live local now